I was overjoyed to view your appearance
on the shorty award did a fabulous job
for the Shorty Awards are like to
Twitter big yeah I'm yeah I burned a
bridge Adam went up and did it's like 10
minutes yeah there was a long time yeah
but just immediately from the time you
got there you were [ __ ] all over and
not in like a fun way you know oh I hate
this place way well over everything
I you know I really it's tough like I I
was really just goofing around you know
and and the vibe of the room was very
loose and the right before I went on
someone was like you know go be funny
you know and I was like okay and the
funniest thing about what was going on
that night was that like I wasn't gonna
go on and do material and like you know
and that's why they brought me in was to
you know be funny and I I've seen my
fair share of award shows like I knew
where we were in the paradigm of what
was going on yeah you know but I do feel
I do feel bad that people whose job it
is to do that stuff and like I didn't
want like I didn't want to my goal was
not to make anyone feel bad about their
job yeah you know I didn't I'm glad you
did but um so good because I said like
there's been uh it's weird it's like the
internet choose you out it you know it I
didn't expect to get mad at you yeah not
only the content creators but like
multiple there's like a bunch of
negative it wasn't a great thing like my
family wasn't psyched to read headlines
Adam pally gets kicked off of award show
right like and so but you didn't
actually not want to be there no look
I'm promoting a movie and it was part of
the press junket and I knew what I was
doing like sigh a lot of people like
why'd he even goes like well I went to
do that I was there I went to be funny
and that's and to me it's funny and I
look back
and I go is funny the bummer of it to me
to be on it besides besides the fact
that people are were offended which I
really honestly like didn't hot I was
just joking around and you can either
take it as a joke or not but I'm not
gonna apologize for it
the bummer of it was that like I was one
sentence away from being done right and
I think it wouldn't have been as big a
story I think it would have just been a
funny bit at an award show but if you
watch it what actually happens is the
singer she does not work for the award
show she's just a singer who won an
award earlier in the night so imagine
like the Internet's Kesha okay you know
sitting at the Grammys she sees what's
happening and she thinks she's going to
run on and save the day
because it sent out there by the show no
she did it on her own and when she gets
up there she starts reading the copy and
she goes this is really inappropriate
now but we are doing an in memoriam she
didn't know that the in memoriam wasn't
as a GUI it was a goof and the end so
she kind of like made it seem like it
was something it wasn't right like and
so that was why I got removed and like
it was like I was like oh yeah and that
was the bummer the whole thing was like
it would have just been a funny bit so
it's gonna be an [ __ ]
no no I I don't think she's being here
so I think she was like didn't know it's
like she'd quite get what was going on
yeah what was going on she didn't get
what I was doing and she really thought
that I was about to make a mockery of an
in memoriam I don't know in her mind who
they were going to in memorialize right
but I was clearly joking around about
the fact that they were in memorializing
with them so what they did was they did
like an immemorial of social media sites
that are no longer active which is like
MySpace and Sangha and like those web
sites and Adam does this thing where
he's like he starts reading the
teleprompter and then he's like
exhausting because I don't know we're
gonna do some [ __ ] where we put up
MySpace and stuff and kind of made a
goof on it but as he's doing that
this girl walks out of nowhere and just
goes like ah they wanted me to come and
save the show and then she does the
thing where she says this is really
awkward
she was this notion this is
inappropriate inappropriate
inappropriate yeah she thinks we're
going to an immemorial
we're going to an actual in memoriam and
so that was the other bummers like you
can't even I don't want to say this
without being crude and then I kinda
don't want to talk about it because I
don't want it like this to be my I
really don't want to be known as the
shortest guy the bummer of it is that
you can't even really joke around you
can't even really do comedy in that
space anymore because people can't even
get they they can't even get a joke
they're dopes it's like there's a there
so they they don't even they can't even
see what is happening there's just like
this wide eye like there's no base level
of reality so you can't joke around
because it's all just like you know
floating you know it's like I was just
really mystified at the fact that like
people didn't get it or people were like
at one point in the middle of adam's
presentation of the award he's like
doing the whole thing and then he just
kind of stops and he's like I know I'm
up here and I'm killing it just you know
when Kelly uh yeah the way I wanted to
be yeah yeah you know like people
laughing and uncomfortable I was a
hearty amount of both the people that I
wanted to laugh were dying like The
Daily Show dudes and like their staff
that was there and and like the queer
eye guys who I think are funny like they
loved it and that to me was like and
that's me was where my barometer was
because I had seen the rest of the room
where I was like oh I don't care
thank you cuz he goes where he goes like
I'm up here killing and he goes but if
you guys are gonna come to me and ask me
to host this thing next year it's a hard
pass
[Laughter]
yeah I don't know man I want to work I I
got kids I really like that's the issue
right you were trying to be funny not
like declare war yeah yeah and I am NOT
like you know I am NOT like the brand
anti brand guy like I love brands like
I'm all branded out man like I I love
brands and I love popular culture and
I'm on Twitter and Instagram sometimes I
wish I wasn't but I am and this is
that's not me either I was just simply
you know doing a bit and and I in and
this will the this will make it worse
because people love will will be upset
that I was doing a like this what I've
done right now today was made it worse
but it's really it's okay like he said
they were dopes you're fine no I you
said that I agreed but no because it
because it I don't know I really like I
I wasn't seeking to hurt anybody
right I was just seeking a like a bit of
comedy you making fun of something I was
making fun of yeah you know and and and
I was hoping and I and I and I was and I
know that not everybody's gonna love
everything right but I also like and I
and I know as a comic for my entire life
that I that I don't shouldn't care right
but for some reason I do feel like
bummed out by it it bums me out